[Musique]
nous vous avons présenté en janvier
dernier l'histoire de madame victoria ce
squelette que l'on a retrouvé sur un
terrain de l'hôpital royal victoria à
montréal
un squelette que l'on a jamais identifié
ce dossier non résolus a suscité
beaucoup de réaction de votre part
ce qui a permis à la police ce explorer
de nouvelles pistes
mais avant revenons sur cette histoire
très intrigante le 13 juin 2001 dans un
stationnement de l'hôpital royal
victoria en plein centre ville de
montréal
une infirmière trouve un crâne près de
sa voiture le reste du squelette est
revêtu d'une chemise et d'un pantalon
d'hôpital associés habituellement au
personnel médical
on ne vérifie si des personnes portées
disparues l'automne et on en avait pas
le dossier de madame victoria se
retrouvent ensuite entre les mains de la
célèbre anthropologue judiciaire kathy
reichs elle conclut que le squelette est
celui d'une femme blanche qui serait âgé
entre 50 et 70 ans
le squelette avait beaucoup de astier
prose et aussi beaucoup de la retraite
en 2003 la grc va réaliser une
approximation faciale le visage
énigmatique de madame victoria circule
dans plusieurs hôpitaux de montréal
personne ne peut l'identifier la police
lance un appel à tous des tests d'adn
sont effectuées tous négatifs en 2010
enquête découvre qu'à l'université
d'ottawa les chercheurs travaillent sur
la mémoire des cheveux qui renferme de
l'information sur l'eau que l'on boit
sur ce qu'on mange sur les lieux que
l'on a fréquenté ce qui va relancer le
dossier
si sadi a tout balayé ça peut nous
donner des indicateurs de
de ses déplacements maman victoria s'est
beaucoup déplacé durant les quatre
dernières années de sa vie du nord du
québec vers le sud à la suite de la
diffusion de ce reportage
nous avons reçu de nombreux courriels
d'ex employés de l'hôpital royal
victoria
nous on écrit
derrière nous c'est aline mémoriaux
l'endroit où sont reçus les patients
diagnostiqués quatre îlots geneviève
girard a une théorie pour expliquer la
présence des vêtements sur le squelette
les fameuses chroniques on appelle
plutôt les vêtements de bloc opératoire
donc vert ou bleu c'est facile et
accessible surtout dans les bacs qui
sont qui vont être acheminées au lavage
il ya toutes sortes de monde dans un
hôpital
c'est facile de se promener puis d'aller
mettre la main sur quelque chose qui
serait dans un petit placard non
surveillé
sandra kourdi a travaillé comme
infirmière au royal victoria
les est inhérent main quand il rentre à
l'urgence les vêtements étaient trop
abîmés ou trop sale quand on leur donner
congé pour rentrer à la maison
vous avez pu nettement parfois on allait
directement la salle d'eau puis on
allait chercher des efforts parce qu'on
n'avait rien d'autre
parmi les courriels trois informations
ont mené la police a demandé des tests
d'adr une dame croit reconnaître une
secrétaire qui a travaillé dans une
clinique médicale
hélène bédard est porté disparu depuis
janvier 2000 elle était hospitalisée à
l'hôtel du québec
elle a eu une permission de sortie et
n'est jamais revenu et pour les
certaines correspondances au niveau de
la grandeur au niveau de l'enjeu
c'est quelqu'un m'a quitté ce pays un
type scada trick de notoriété retrouvé
près de son psychiatre illégal la police
retrouve son frère pour effectuer un
prélèvement adn
les premiers résultats nous arrive
quelques mois plus tard négatif encore
une fois une autre information nous
vient de lévis pierrette bouffard
disparu en janvier 1997 elle était
atteint de schizophrénie et vivait dans
une famille d'accueil elle est disparue
lors d'une tempête de neige
on attend toujours les résultats adn
et enfin une autre disparition
mystérieuse celle de marie josée racines
infirmière à l'hôpital sainte justine
elle était dépressive on a retrouvé sa
voiture au mont tremblant est à leur
portée
ni sa sacoche ni carte d'identité ni
bijoux elle avait un dentier en beau
pays madame victorieux aussi elle
faisait beaucoup des retraites aussi
avec ses mains au niveau mental elle
était assez malade et policiers sont
venus chez moi pour faire un test adn
ils nous ont dit qu'on aurait un
résultat
c2s mois le mois de novembre c'est le
sixième mois qu'on est toujours en
attente lot de d'avoir le résultat est
drôle de hasard
mélanie est née à l'hôpital royal
victoria nous vous tiendrons au courant
des résultats d' adn quant aux policiers
ils croient que le secret de l'énigme
réside quelque part dans les archives de
l'hôpital un hôpital qui a toujours
refusé de nous parler